when the war happened and we were
trapped in this incredibly violent and
dangerous time when my friends were good
were dying I was able to get on the last
commercial plane at left my country
before it totally closed for 20 years
because I was so lucky I thought I write
an ode to me to a story that is about me
but without my luck so I'm really
honored to be today here with them with
my ex army safe i love you which is an
amazing Louisville that I didn't I could
not like it out of my mind it's about
this little girl she's a female soldiers
like just in the start of her life she
goes from her a small town in New York
to the Middle East and fight the world
and then comes back home with PTSD
so you will be about people that are
essentially torn between trying to be
the strongest man in the room trying to
be the good life and still not
accomplishing that
thank you very much I'm so happy and I'm
so proud to be here you know it's very
funny when you live in a fan for example
and you have an internet and you see the
website and this is the Sundance
Institute but this completes assumption
was right about
you